and you're not owning up to the
consequences of it
i don't know what to say
i don't know what to say um i just think
men don't have no rights putting their
opinion towards it that's that's why i
can say towards it men have no right
yeah
when it comes to abortion they should
never say why why do you think that ends
because it's a woman's body so i have a
woman that's going to push it out yeah
not them that's going to go through it i
have a question do you think since it's
a woman's body do you feel like we
should be able to have abortions a month
before we give bor give birth
a month before it shouldn't even reach a
month i know what i'm saying if it's my
body shouldn't it like wouldn't you say
based on that logic it's my body might
be a month if you wanted never wanted it
then you should have been careful with
you know i i agree but i but don't you
think they should have been careful
before it was born like because a lot of
girls will have sex with guys that
shouldn't be fathers and instead of
being more selective with who we sleep
with and maybe being on birth control we
make poor decisions and then this is
just like a way to be bailed out
basically yeah that's true that is true
and so do you think that's a problem you
don't think that's a problem someone
don't deserve to be fathers at all
because
some men don't deserve to be fathers
though
we shouldn't be sleeping with them right
yeah that's true did you know that forty
percent of women that get abortions
they've had two or more no i didn't know
that so it's like we're we keep seeing
women it's like we're just not being
careful clearly not four percent is
almost 50. what 40 is almost 50. yeah
and that means 60 it's their first one
we don't know how many they'll have in
the future just becoming like a cop-out
as opposed to being responsible with our
body i really i think babies are alive
so if you never wanted it don't like
just take it away life is life you know
so you're pro-life yeah oh i'm confused
i'm confused right now g okay i didn't i
misunderstood you when you said my body
my choice no no i'm pro-life yeah what
made you prolong the simple fact that
not everyone can have babies
and like everyone always want that
opportunity people have like
miscarriages and like try and try
and yeah
what do you what do you think to the
people that say that like it's too much
of an overreach like it's our body you
shouldn't have done it then they're
simple they oh my god thank you that's
like i've never find girls that agree
with me this is okay okay
do you have any social media you want to
play um yeah six more six i x m u lla
thank you so much have a good one
um so today we're talking about that we
i think abortion is a cop-out you mean
like it's just like uh it's like oh i
forgot now i can just get an abortion i
think i think most women make poor
decisions
and they're not being careful and what
was supposed to be a last resort is now
becoming a cop-out for poor decision but
there's so but it's so broad there's so
many different types of abortions okay
so like how what are you defining as an
abortion do you do is plan b an abortion
yes or no what what say you okay so i
don't i don't have an opinion on plan b
because i honestly don't know enough
about plan b
so i'm so broad i'm talking about the
the data that i'm talking about was
taken from abortion centers so it's not
it's not including plan b i'm saying i'm
saying it's not like it's such a broad
here all i know i was telling your
friend over here is that i'm a father of
two daughters
and you know you know what you know what
my opinion should be
my opinion should be shut the [ __ ] up
brandon
but i can have a voice cause i'm a girl
right of course sir what
i don't even i'm saying for me my dog
like i'm if i sit around the dinner
table i'm not allowed i shouldn't have
an opinion
really i think men should have an
opinion it's their kid this is why we
have a lack of masculinity in society
guys stop letting women tell you that
you can't have an opinion because you're
a man if anything we should listen to
men we should listen to men we're
emotional we get on our period once a
month we're crazy we are nuts and men
don't have that so if you don't go to
men for logic what what do we have in a
society and we our society is so
brainwashed that we have convinced men
that they can't have an opinion
on
a child that is half theirs that they
helped make
you don't think okay you don't think
your daughters you you would rather
teach them to be careful with who they
sleep with well no but you know what i
am doing i'm i'm not i'm not hiding
meaning that i don't we're open at every
we're opening like were your parents
open with you at the table like were you
afraid were you able to say anything
will you be able to ask them anything
and would they honestly give you the
answers yeah
well that's good because that's how
that's our approach our approach is like
you know what this is this is what an
iud is this is you know where you know
have your guy wear a condom go on the
pill because you know what there's some
parents that don't talk about the pill
okay and they're like god forbid i don't
want to talk about the pill because you
know i don't think my kid is
sexually active when in reality they
could be teen pregnancies are actually
dropping and the majority of abortions
are actually over the age of 21. so i
just think if you're getting an abortion
if you're getting an abortion over the
age of 21 you you know the reproductive
you you know and i think look it's like
too old i respect your opinion i respect
his opinion and his opinion i respect
everybody's opinion so that's that's
what mine so but i'm not judging anybody
so if you believe that but everybody
should be able to choose what they want
to do
okay so today we're talking about
abortion yeah so my my statement is that
in the majority of case in a case's
abortion is a cop-out okay i'm from new
york what do you mean about a cop house
like what does that what does that mean
so basically it it means that you made a
poor choice and you don't want to deal
with the consequences okay i disagree i
think that having and deciding to have
an abortion is actually a choice of
power and courage and you're
acting over your body and your decision
and being a parent deciding to be a
parent and to be a mother is such a
great deal then forcing a kid to grow up
when you don't have the economical or
mental issues and reasons to like birth
and like carry a child i think it like
it doesn't make any sense so the
misconception is that people that are
poorer are more likely to get abortions
only eight percent of women below the
poverty line are getting abortions where
women that make forty seven thousand
dollars per year or more one out of
three get abortion so it's not really an
economic issue yeah but it doesn't have
to do with economic it has to do with
your mental health if you don't want to
have a child then you shouldn't bring a
child into the world but don't you think
they should be more careful when they're
having sex then
like yeah but accidents happen and that
doesn't mean that you have to like have
a child because i think it's worse for
you to have it than to have an abortion
because it doesn't make any sense so the
problem is 40 of women that have
abortions they've had two or more
already so it's not necessarily like the
majority of women and they don't track
out of the 60 who get them in the future
no no i don't think like i don't think
that's accurate and like also from
planned parenthood and looking about
like person like yeah that might be
accurate but at the same time it's a
personal decision so like every woman
has to make a choice over their body
because it's their body and it has
nothing to do with like whether society
says it has to do or whether it happens
or not happens and the fact that
abortion is now being like real versus
weight is being overruled in new york is
such a sad thing that happened and it
makes you think like oh my god if this
is happening then what happens to my
rights then what happens to me
i have the right to be abstinent yeah i
think you have you have the right to not
go through an abortion and carry for the
pregnancy at the same time time another
woman has a right to not carry and go on
within okay so here's here's my question
do you think abortion should be legal up
to birth
because you said my body my choice so
when i think of my body my choice like
even the week before i give birth it's
still my body my choice and this is the
question they can't answer if it's my
body my choice then stand on that logic
abortion should be legal up to birth
stand on it
or don't have the argument at all